the gigafactory is really vital for the
future of Tesla in order to produce this
mass market affordable electric car
which has been our goal from the
beginning and and so in deciding where
should we place this we had to say okay
where are we going to have high
confidence that this factory is going to
be ready on time so that when we're
ready to produce the the vehicle the
factory is ready to produce the battery
packs that was in that was truly the
most important thing and then of course
can we operate that factory if
cost-effectively so that the car itself
can be affordable it's worth perhaps
just highlighting the the sheer scale of
the of the Giga factory and why do we
even call it the Giga factory it's
because it's actually going to be it's
not just gonna be the biggest
lithium-ion battery factory in the world
but it'll actually be bigger than the
sum of all the Theia my own factories in
the world so if you add up all the
lithium ion factories in China Korea
Japan else
elsewhere in the world and you sum them
all up it on all of their production
capability last year the Giga factory is
actually bigger than that so it's it's
it's difficult to quite describe in
words but it's it's it's a heck of a big
factory the factory will actually be
shaped like a diamond
and the reason for that is it if you
make it a box shape it would have had we
would have had to move a lot more earth
so in order to sort of have it fit more
in the environment we've had a shape
like diamond and then it's it's aligned
on on True North so that we can actually
have the we can map out where the
equipment's going to be by GPS and and
we can also the solar panels that will
be on the roof are also properly aligned
so it's sort of I guess sounds kind of I
think it sounds kind of romantic to say
it's shaped like a diamond and aligned
to true north but there are practical
reasons for it as well